Hi, I'm hank green
And I'm John Green. Here at crash course our mission is to create quality
educational content that we can release for free for everyone forever
Thanks to our patrons on patreon as well as support from PBS Digital Studios. We've been able to keep this channel growing
We're currently uploading five videos a week Monday through Friday
And we've been able to work with so many wonderful people to bring you series like Mythology, computer science, sociology,
film, world history, astronomy, chemistry,
Economics, psychology, physics, and more. with the support we get we can focus on creating series
We think will be the most valuable not just the ones that will get the most views and we're so thankful for that. Like in
like in 2018 we will be doing series on engineering, theater in drama, the history of science, media literacy, and statistics
We recently made some changes to our patreon so we wanted to give you an update on what's going on over there. Our animation team
Thought Cafe has already been designing sweet digital rewards for our patrons
And now they're designing
exclusive
physical rewards as well for various pledge amounts you can get a laptop sticker sent to you every month, a new lapel pin on a
Quarterly basis and/or an annual mystery reward. This will be a cool piece of merchandise
We will create once and then never again
But you won't know for sure what it's gonna be
just promise you that it's gonna be great all these physical rewards are being designed only for crash course patreon patrons
It's our way of saying thank you for making this thing that we do possible. Please have some swag
We've also added a merch discount code to a reward levels
You can get 20% off crash course merch at dftba.com as well as a level for outtakes
You can get access to behind-the-scenes photos and videos featuring your favorite celebrities like
Instagram sensation
Abby the Corgi. And if you pledge just $1 or more per month you can get access to a monthly live stream with the crash
Course team you'll be able to talk to us in the chat and ask us all of your burning questions
Higher-level patrons are also invited into the Hangout to talk with us in real-time face-to-face.
These livestreams are so fun and so valuable to us.
We really love being able to interact with you in this format and hear your thoughts if $1 a month is your thing know that
That goes a long way, and we can't wait to see you in those live streams
Those live streams have only been available at higher monthly donation amounts
But we've moved it down to $1.00 because we want to have bigger broader
conversations of course if you can't afford to be a patron that is
Absolutely hundred-percent totally cool the whole thing is that these videos are free
And we want them to exist for people to watch without having to pay. Regardless
We are grateful to all of you for being part of this community with us
We hope to see you over on our patreon link of the doobly-doo, but whether we do or not
Thank you for being here for watching this for sharing crash course for enjoying it and as we say in our hometown
Don't forget to be awesome